طبعا المشاغبون معروفون هم يندسون باعداد
صغيره شخصين او ثلاثه داخل دائره الغضب
الكرديه التي يشارك فيها شبان وفتيات ايضا
مسالمون ومسالمات من ابناء الجاليه
الكرديه ستستطيعين بسهوله ان تميزه ونحن
بخبراتنا على الارض على مدى ثلاثين عاما
في باريس ميسون نستطيع بسهوله ان نميز
المشاغب والمندس في صفوف المجموعات
المسالمه والذين جاءوا للاحتجاج بشكل سلمي
قوه كبرى تصل في هذه اللحظات قوه كبيره من
الشرطه من وحدات التدخل السريع في الشرطه
الفرنسيه وصلت الى هنا اعداد كبيره
تشاهدين عناصر الشرطه ينزلون
من الشاحنات من سياراتهم عفوا
ويتدخلون هنا يدخلون الى هذه الجاده التي
حصرت فيها قبل دقائق من الان قوه من
الشرطه اذا وحدات التدخل هل تسمعينني جيدا
ميسون
انت على الهواء مباشره
[موسيقى]
نعم اترك المصور ايضا
ينقل ما يجري
هناك نيران اشعلت في وسط جده
ستراسبور هنا هذه الجاده التي قطعها
المحتاجون الغاضبون قطعوا السير فيها
ووصلت قوات من وحدات التدخل السريع في
الشرطه الفرنسيه لنجده عناصر من الشرطه
حصروا بدا هجوم قوات التدخل السريعه
تشاهدين قوه التدخل السريع التي نزل
عناصرها من سياراتهم من الياتهم يتدخلون
لدفع المحتاجين الغاضبين الى داخل الاحياء
التي تتفرع عن جده ستراسبور في قلب
العاصمه الفرنسيه
اعدادهم كبيره اذا من عناصر قوات التدخل
السريع هناك حال من الفوضى بالنسبه
للسكان الذين حصلوا داخل سياراتهم في وقت
الانصراف من العمل ميسون لا يعرفون ما
الذي يجري بعضهم يسالون من داخل سيارته ما
الذي يحصل هنا بعضهم لم يعلم بما جرى منذ
ظهور اليوم هنا في باريس يسالون وهم
محاصرون داخل سياراتهم عماره